hey guys I just wanted to say goodbye to  my family we spent a good long time  together for Christmas and New Year's  and all the other holidays I've been  here for three weeks straight and I'm  headed back to LA as of the time you're  watching this video so go by Luigi's  goodbye goodbye goodbye maybe I need one  goodbye bye Thomas  good boy good block BYE MOM bye bye so  I'll be back in LA making videos just as  soon as I can  and it'll be back to the normal schedule  and get ready for lots of cool videos  I've done a lot of cool things just  hanging out with my friends while I'm  here and it's been a good time it's been  a good time so thank you everybody for  being patient while I've been taking a  very long vacation and I'll see you back  in LA all right not biting you guys  you're literally gonna see me the same  time as normal Oh God